je rajoute ce petit message avant de
commencer la vidéo il ya une bande
dessinée qui va sortir sur l'univers de
youtube c'est énorme je n'allais pas
pouvoir la trouver dans le commerce et
je vous en parle dans une vidéo qui est
juste dans cette description en ont
répertorié
est ce que j'ai un personnage d'adam
salut après cette vidéo vous allez être
capable de retenir un numéro de
téléphone en entier comme ça à la volée
ou n'importe quelle séquence de chiffres
genre carte bleue code d'entrée d'un
immeuble ou que du wi fi le truc
vraiment cool c'est que vous allez
pouvoir réussir à faire ça à la fin de
cette vidéo vous suivez cette vidéo à la
fin bîmes
vous êtes capable de le faire pour ça on
va utiliser une version très simplifiée
de la table de rappel et du palais
mental qui sont deux techniques de
mémoire que vous connaissez si vous
suivez la chaîne alors peut-être que
vous avez jamais le prix le temps sur
une table de rappel ou un palais mentale
et peut-être que vous en avez déjà un
peu importe parce que c'est toujours
important voire essentiel d'avoir
plusieurs tables de rappel en fonction
de l'utilisation est ce qu'on va mettre
en place la qui va être très court va
vous permettre de retenir de manière
temporaire mais moyen terme
exemple concret on vous dira numéro
téléphone vous n'avez pas de communauté
vous allez le retenir peut-être jusqu'au
soir même où jusqu'au lendemain ou jusqu
au surlendemain le temps de le noter
quelque part ou de le rentrer quelque
part petite nouveauté également sur la
chaîne systématiquement mettant à la fin
de chaque vidéo il y aura un écran
durant deux secondes donc vous pourrez
faire peau si vous avez envie de lire
sur lequel vous allez retrouver la date
de la prochaine vidéo le jour et l'heure
où elle va sortir le prochain live les
dates et endroits où est-ce que j'ai
dédicacé livrer toutes les infos que je
trouvais pertinentes à m et maintenant
on attaque la méthode je voulais dit à
la fin de cette vidéo là vous serez
capable de faire ça donc joué le jeu en
même temps que je vous parle rester un
petit peu faux cul sur la vidéo est pour
vous motiver regarder le temps que fait
la vidéo et dites vous qu à la fin vous
serez capable de le faire on va
commencer par créer une connexion entre
les neurones qui représente les chiffres
de 0 à 9 et des images ça va être une
sorte de code secret pour le zéro je
vous demande et d'imaginer un oeuf dans
votre esprit vous pouvez fermer les yeux
d'ailleurs à chaque étape si vous voulez
mieux visualiser ça et vous allez
verbalisé à voix haute ou peut-être en
chuchotant suivant le monde qu'à hauteur
de vous 0 c'est un 9 à 9 1 019 vous
pouvez aussi faire les gestes fait le
jeu vous laisse quelques secondes avec
mon f
ok maintenant on va passer aux 1 le 1
c'est une grande tige comme ça et bien
on va imaginer que un c'est la tour
eiffel visualiser la tour eiffel et
essayez d'imaginer que ces 1 1 et à
linverse izia lisez 1,1 à imaginer que
c'est une tour eiffel vous allez
connecter tout ça ensemble
certains ont peut-être envie de me dire
oui mais moi je suis pas un visuel au
niveau de la mémoire peu importe en fait
on a tous une très bonne mémoire
visuelle chacun une prédominance
ailleurs mais le visuel fonctionne pour
tout le monde le 1
la tour eiffel je vous laisse faire pour
le 2 c'est très facile on a imaginé un
signe parce que le 2 cette courbe là
avec ce trait ça rappelle un petit peu
un signe qui serait sur un étang par
exemple là aussi visualiser le 2 le
single sign 2 vous pouvez le répéter
vous pouvez le visualiser vous pouvez
aussi faire des mouvements comme ça vous
allez voir ça prend que quelques
secondes à chaque fois n'hésitez pas à
mettre pause pour 2 3 secondes histoire
de visualiser sans m'entendre parler en
même temps et donc le numéro deux et on
va passer aux 3 et le 3 ça va être une
bouche alors je vous explique pourquoi
j'ai fait une bouche pour le 3 parce que
ça ça me rappelle les bouches des
dessins du style lucky luke où souvent
les dessinateurs dessiner la bouche
comme ça pour mettre un brin d'herbe ou
une cigarette dedans où vous dites je
sais c'est immonde quand je dessine le 3
la bouche fait pas aussi vous avez
besoin de trois comptes de plus et on
passe au numéro 4 le numéro 4 ça va être
une planche à voile
simplement parce que cette grande elle
comme ça peut rappeler la voile d'une
planche à voile visualiser le 4 la
planche à voile fait la connexion entre
ça vous pouvez le verbaliser vous pouvez
encore faire les gestes pour mater
réaliser tout ça dans votre esprit et on
passe aux 5 le 5 qui ressemble un petit
peu un sc qu'on prononce savard ap le
serpent prenez le temps de visualiser un
serpent en forme de s dans votre esprit
on a presque terminé pour les chiffres
le ciss qui sera un sachet de thé parce
que j'ai l'impression de voir un fils
avec quelque chose au bout comme un
sachet de thé qu'on pourrait tremper
dans l'eau chaude vous pouvez même
visualiser ainsi ce que vous êtes en
train de tremper dans de l'eau chaude et
on attaque le set avec la lampe de
bureau le set on pourrait vraiment
imaginer que c'est une lampe de bureau
parce qu'on a cette pige comme ça qui
part du bas et ça revient comme ça on
pourrait imaginer un éclairage donc
visualiser votre lampe de bureau et vous
voyez le 7 dans cette lampe de bureau
plus que deux d'ailleurs deux je vous le
rappelle celle singh le 8 à retenir vous
allez voir c'est extrêmement simple se
doubleront comme ça vous le faites
tomber et ça nous fait une paire de
lunettes donc 8 lunettes lunettes 8,6
vous même vous avez des lunettes vous
pouvez même imaginer que ça aille vite
que vous avez sur les yeux et pour finir
le neuf le 9 savez une pâquerette
imaginer que cette barre du neuf c'est
une tige qui sort du sol et que le
cercle comme ça c'est l'intérieur d'une
pâquerettes c'est juste une pâquerette
sur lequel il manquerait les pétales
peut-être qu'ils sont tombés on n'en
sait rien en 0 on visualise 1 901
c'est une tour eiffel en deux vous avez
1 signant 3 vous avez une bouche le 4
c'est donc une planche à voile vous
visualisez l'ale de la planche à voile
le 5
c'est le s de serpents en 6 on voit bien
le sachet de thé contre en tout y en sep
c'est la lampe de bureau
8 c'est la paire de lunettes et le neuf
avec la pâquerette
je vous fais un petit test et après on
attaque la fin de la méthode le test
pour consolider sa c'est que je vous dis
si vous essayez de retrouver l'image qui
est associé après celle inverse jeudi
l'image vous essayez de retrouver deux
chiffres alors on commence par le 3 le 3
quelle est l'image qui est associé vous
voyez bien la forme du 3 essayez de vous
rappeler je compte jusqu'à 2 c'est une
bouche on inverse love ces quelques
chiffres
visualisez l'efs chercher le chiffre
associés je compte jusqu'à 2 c les héros
évidemment c'est le même fort le 8 à
quelle image correspond ce chiffre-là le
visualisez 8 et je compté jusqu'à 2 vous
retrouver l'image c'est la paire de
lunettes
évidemment s'en fait un dernier quel
chiffre est associé à une pâquerette de
pâquerettes
j'allais dire qu'a pu les pétales mais
c'est un bon indice a quand même je
compte jusqu'à 1
oui c'est le nom maintenant je suis
persuadé que vous avez bien ces
correspondances chiffres image en tête
on va créer un mini pad et mentale
rapidement qui vous servira ensuite
accumulé votre table de rappel pour
retenir ce que vous voulez j'expliquerai
ça rapidement à la fin imprimantes elle
c'est évidemment un lieu imaginaire ou
qu'ils existent et dont vous connaissez
tous les détails dans votre esprit et
c'est un lieu où il ya un circuit un
trajet donc je vais prendre un lieu
générique où je suis sûr qu'on va
retrouver les mêmes choses et les mêmes
objets et que vous connaissez forcément
parker dans votre salle de bain ya
forcément un lavabo il ya forcément une
douche ou baignoire ya forcément une
porte pour entrer il a forcément une
lampe quelque part au plafond ou
ailleurs et ya forcément un meuble ou un
placard ou une étagère
ça va être les cinq endroits qu'on va
imaginer comme je peux pas faire un
circuit logique genre en ce sens horaire
ou anti horaire puisque chacun a sa
salle de bain le trajet sur les
suivantes vous pouvez fermer les yeux si
vous voulez et je vais vous demander
d'imaginer pour commencer votre douche
douche ou baignoire évidemment ça c'est
l'endroit numéro un la douche ou la
baignoire
ensuite toujours mentalement vous aller
visualiser la lampe ou le lampadaire ou
le luminaire ça ce sera l'endroit numéro
2 donc la douche et ensuite la lampe
visualiser en troisième position le
lavabo il ya forcément un lavabo quelque
part vous le visualiser aussi donc enfin
la douche en deux la lampe en 3 le
lavabo en 4e vous visualisez votre
placard ou une étagère si vous avez pas
de placards et en cinquième et dernière
étape vous visualisez la porte comme si
vous sortiez de la salle de bain alors
il ya quand même un sens logique à tout
ce trajet c'est un ordre alphabétique
c'est à dire quand on a la douche en
deux on alla l'enfant-roi le lavabo en 4
le placard ou étagères ou meubles et en
5 la porte on se refait rapidement la
table de rappel en 0 on avait neuf ans
neuf on avait un sacré temps 8 les
minettes en 7 la lampe de bureau en 6
c'est le sachet de thé 1 c'est pas le
plus facile sur l'a15 le serpent aux
quatre la planche à voile en trois la
bouche en double signe enfin la tour est
fait et on se refait rapidement le
bâtiment
simplifiez vous êtes dans votre salle de
bain est d'abord vous visualisez la
douche ensuite la lampe ensuite le
lavabo ensuite le meuble placard
l'étagère et pour terminer vous sortez
par la porte avant de passer à la
dernière étape qui est la plus simple
après tout ce qu'on a fait c'est juste
la réunification des deux je vous
félicite déjà d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo en entier et d'avoir pris que ces
quelques minutes dans votre vie pour
maintenant réussir à faire ça tout le
temps bravo je vous poussant les reese
pour vous faire voir le fonctionnement
on va prendre le cas très concret d'un
numéro de téléphone donc là c'est des
chiffres mais vous comprendrez assez
bien la méthode pour pouvoir appliquer à
n'importe quelle séquence de 12 suivent
d'aucun suivie de trois chiffres de 4
chiffres
vous aurez l'outil simplifier la méthode
vous auriez vu juste ensuite l'adapter
vous même c'est pas très compliqué alors
on va imaginer numéro téléphone qui
n'existe pas le 81 18 76 54 32 10
en situation de dix numéros téléphone
j'ai rien pour noter je veux retenir et
je veux être sûre de moi quand je le
retiens parce que faire une boucle
phonétique se tient pas longtemps c'est
à dire le répéter en boucle dans sa tête
là on veut être sûrs de leur tier 1
moyen terme le temps de l'écrire quelque
part donc j'ai demandé à la personne de
me le dire lentement nombre par n'ont
donc en premier c'est 98
nous on sait que ces 9 8 et 9 8 c'est
quoi c'est la marguerite et les lunettes
9,8 au premier endroit de mon palais
mentale simplifier c'est à dire la
douche je vais imaginé ces deux objets
en action dans un ordre précis c'est à
dire que la place du pommeau de douche
j'imagine une marguerite géant et du
jeune de la marguerite au lieu que ce
soit de l'eau qui tombe ce sont des
paires de lunettes et je peux déjà passé
à la suite parce que c'est tellement
incongru et on a tellement tout bien
fixés dans notre esprit que dans 2
heures 3 heures 24 heures on se
souviendra en pensant à notre douche de
cette marguerite et des lunettes qui
tombe donc je peux demander le deuxième
nombre qui est 76 donc la lampe de
bureau et le sachet de thé et je vais
mettre dans l'ordre ces deux images en
actions deuxième endroit de mon palais
mental je vous rappelle que c'est la
langue par exemple pour moi c'est mon
plafonnier et donc à la place de mon
plafonnier j'imagine ma lampe de bureau
mais à l'envers en fait qui est suspendu
à l'envers et tout autour de l'ampoulé
je vois des sachets t qui sont suspendus
un peu comme les mobiles qu'on met au
berceau des enfants sains mais un mobile
l'a bien dégueulasse parce que c'est une
ou deux bureaux à l'envers etc des
sachets de thé qui pendouille et vous
pouvez déjà passé à la suite parce que
l'image elle prend une seconde à faire
dans votre esprit et elle se fixe en
troisième celle 54 donc dans votre
lavabo pour ma part instantanément je
penserai que le bec du lavabo c'est un
serpent avec l'eau qui sort et qui est
un petit voilier dans le lavabo
ni voilier qu'est en train de faire de
la voile c'est le but d'un voilier en se
termine rapidement pour aller jusqu'au
bout de l'exemple mon quatrième endroit
dans mon pad et mentale simplifier c'est
mon meuble
donc j'avais imaginé le 32 sur mon
meuble 32 c'est une bouche est un signe
moi mon meuble c'est plutôt une armoire
donc j'imagine une bouche sur le côté
que condom en ouvrir l élève plutôt que
d'ouvrir les portes et à l'intérieur il
y aura un signe resplendissant pleine
lumière qui m'attendent et ensuite je
sortirai ma salle de bains par le
cinquième en droit c'est à dire la porte
la porte pour moi ce serait une tour
eiffel mise à l'échelle de la ma porte
évidemment donc y aura des trous des
trucs comme ça qu'il ya serait un petit
peu plate d'ailleurs mais tour eiffel
mais elle symboliserait le 1 comme les
plus grandes je sais que c'est le
premier est l'oeuf je mettrai en boutons
empoigné avec cet ordre de grandeur un
petit peu comme les actions qu'on s'est
représenté tout à l'heure je sais que
c'est le 1 en premier et le zéro en
deuxième qui me permet d'ouvrir et de
sortir et si mettons 24 heures après
j'essaie de me rappeler tout ça j'ai
juste à me rappeler de ma douche et
instantanément joies de la marguerite
avec les miettes qui tombent après je
repense à mon ampoule et à la place du
plafonnier je vois cette lampe de bureau
avec les sachets de thé comme un mobile
et puis ensuite je pense aux lavabos
donc je vois un serpent et puis je vois
le voilier dans le lavabo et puis
ensuite je pense à mon armoire donc je
vois les bouches avec le signe
resplendissant à l'intérieur et puis
ensuite la porte et je revois la tour
eiffel avec le bouton qui est en fait un
oeuf
essai - 0 cette vidéo est un petit peu
plus longue c'est un peu le format que
je faisais pour les master class de
l'année dernière je pense sincèrement
qu'elle peut être utile soit vous avez
déjà une table de rappel et ça vous en
fais une petite de secours c'est-à-dire
que quand la première est chargée vous
pouvez utiliser celle ci de manière
temporaire
et si vous n'aviez ni tables de rappel
ni plat les mental ça vous fait une
première étape et un premier outil comme
ça pour retenir des chiffres à la rage
des numéros de téléphone etc
à la toute fin de la vidéo vous allez
retrouver ce nouveau rituel avec toutes
les infos là sur un pas de deux secondes
sur lequel vous pouvez me pose pour le
lire merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo
oubliez pas de lalique et de vous
abonner également à très bientôt ciao
[Musique]